the area he helped transform remembered
him as well tonight
tony shea spent years working to improve
downtown las vegas
he left a lifetime impact there and all
across the valley
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
joins us live on fremont street tonight
where a celebration was held in his
honor madison
yes tonight las vegas remember tony shea
with a visual ceremony
that was held in his honor
it's our biggest day of the year while
most knew him as an entrepreneur
los vegas felt a more personal
connection to him
tony shea was the former ceo of zappos
the widely popular shoe and clothing
site
he passed away on friday after he was
hurt in a house fire while visiting
friends in new london connecticut
on november 18th las vegas upset by the
news know him most for his work
downtown he basically made it a
beautiful place for artists and creators
and people to come in and build
something
branding from the ground up he
revitalized the downtown area
made it a place people wanted to come to
his goal
make downtown the most community focused
large city
in the world amber true a local of vegas
said years ago she used to work on the
strip
she would see him a lot it's very sad
like he did a lot of good stuff out here
i personally knew him when i used to
work out on this strip like governor
sisselak tweeting this
on twitter tony shea played a pivotal
role in helping transform
downtown las vegas derrick stevens the
owner of circa and several other high
profile hotels around town
tweeted this and comedian jimmy kimmel
also said
tony was a brilliant creative and
generous person who did great things for
las vegas
this is terrible news tonight's tribute
took a more peaceful approach
playing tranquil music along the hustle
and bustle of the crowd
showing that he was appreciated and will
be greatly missed
and the tribute from fremont street
experience is still going on until
midnight so make sure to check that out
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now